hey guys how we doing hope all is well
today I'd like to talk about a
conversation I've been seeing all over
the place recently which is the Eldon
Ring versus God of War Ragnarok Game of
the Year debate I don't really
understand the argument because
obviously stray is going to win no
question about it it's a cute cat game
but jokes aside I believe everyone's
sort of missing the point when having
this conversation in the first place now
obviously I'm a bit biased because this
channel is mainly Elden ring it's what
blew up my channel earlier this year so
yes it's my personal game of the year
I'm going to vote Elden ring as Game of
the Year it's opinion based it's a vote
so that means whichever game is your
favorite doesn't have to be Elden ring
or God of War you can vote for that game
without having to defend your opinion to
everybody if it was truly your favorite
game that you played this year then vote
for that and anyone giving you Flack for
voting for one game over another that
person probably has an unhealthy relay
relationship with the game that they
prefer but let's look at it from a
different perspective all of these games
are fantastic in their own unique ways
and obviously people are going to have
their own preferences Elden ring is a
massive open world game that tells you
nothing on the surface you have to read
tons of item descriptions to get the
deeper meaning to the overall story
there's no Quest markers and basically
nothing telling you where to go or what
to do besides this ominous glowing light
that more so leads you toward death than
the proper right direction and some
people don't like that some people like
to be told and shown the story at face
value they like Quest markers and lists
the check off and if you do prefer that
style of game you are going to love
every game on this list except for Elden
ring the main argument that I'm seeing
is that some people believe that Elden
ring doesn't have a story at all that's
right some people actually believe that
Elden ring has no narrative story three
whatsoever anyone who says that
obviously didn't pay enough attention
while playing the game because there is
a very simple narrative understanding of
the story of what you are trying to do
in Elden ring and they tell you all of
it from the very start of the game the
Elden ring has been broken and you are
summoned back to the lands between to
fix it that's your entire purpose fix
the Elden ring and become the Eldon Lord
and I'll tell you through my first
playthrough that is all I needed that
was my only objective was to become the
Elden Lord and I definitely didn't ask
why at any point now if you're trying to
understand the why to all of it that's
where you're gonna have to go down a
major Rabbit Hole to figure it all out
here's the thing if you're calling Elden
ring bad design for the way that they
made the story or the way they told the
story then you just don't understand
different types of narrative design in
video games and you're probably just
frustrated that you didn't right away
understand the entire story and you
would prefer if they just told you
everything at face value and I'm here to
tell you that thinking this way is
perfectly fine if it's your personal
preference to experience a story at face
value like Ragnarok then that's
obviously fine but if you're out there
saying to the world of Twitter or
whatever that Elden ring story is poorly
designed or that it barely has a story
to tell then you're a part of the reason
why this debate on Game of the Year is
stupid everything in Elden ring is
designed around a vague story completely
on purpose it is meant to leave you with
this feeling of uncertainty about
everything why did you do everything
you've done throughout the game what are
the true intentions of all of the
characters you met while playing the
game it's meant for all of us as a
community to come together and speculate
on what we think it all means and yes
the story is sometimes frustrating and
confusing that's why I like to take a
break from it from time to time to also
play games like stray and Ragnarok I
don't have to think about the story too
much and that's really nice that doesn't
take away from the creative genius of
Frome software's environmental
storytelling and like I said some people
hate that and that is perfectly fine
while on the flip side some people hate
being told where to go what to do how to
do it and what it all means Eldon ring
and Ragnarok completely succeeded 100 in
how they wanted to tell their own
individual stories Elden ring is meant
to be vague with a focus on
environmental storytelling while
Ragnarok is meant to be this Hollywood
style production that is meant to tell
you the story at face value and there is
nothing wrong with either of these
production Styles but I completely
understand why some people like and
dislike certain aspects of both of these
games that's where a vote comes in you
get to decide what your favorite gaming
experience was
whether your favorite game wins or not
whether Elden ring stray Ragnarok any of
the games whether they win it doesn't
really matter and honestly I didn't even
[ __ ] vote in 2020 or 2021 because I
didn't care about any of the games that
came out I've played the entirety of
Ragnarok since it came out and I can say
that there are some parts of Ragnarok
that I enjoy more than I did Elden ring
Ragnarok improved from the original in
2018 in basically every single way
Ragnarok is a very good game and just
because it's not exactly like Elden ring
doesn't mean I have to dislike it and
hate it I feel like a lot of people do
that and I I don't get it however I'm
picking Elden ring for game of the year
because first off it completely changed
my life it gave me a job creating
content for it that I absolutely love
it's a mental grind every single day
creating content if you're a content
creator out there you know what I'm
talking about it is very mentally taxing
but regardless I love doing it every
single day whether some days are a
struggle more than others whether it
Wins Game of the Year or not it doesn't
matter it was my game of the year I also
believe that eldenring as a whole has
made more of an impact on the gaming
industry than any other game has done in
recent memory it's basically this decade
Skyrim it's such a unique experience
compared to every other game on the
market with hundreds of hours of content
to consume that completely immersed me
into a beautifully constructed open
world and while Ragnarok improved off
its last iteration in 2018 it's
basically the same game from 2018 just
better eldenring took all of their past
games Demon Souls Dark Souls one two
three bloodborne sakuro and mix that all
together into a new IP that [ __ ] blew
my mind in February of this year both
games all the games on the game of the
year list for 2022 are awesome in their
own ways and I think what we all should
be talking about is what an amazing year
it was for gaming in general the last
few years have been complete butt cheeks
in terms of gaming most games coming out
being free to play filled with micro
transactions or they're completely
unfinished that needed months or even
years more of development to even be
close to finished Eldon ring and
Ragnarok said yeah we're not doing any
of that [ __ ] and they did what we all
really want as Gamers they just made a
good [ __ ] game it just feels good to
be a gamer right now I'm very happy
lately I was losing my love for gaming
for a little while there but this year
just completely revitalized all of my
love that I had for it Elden ring and
God of War Ragnarok should not only be
considered game of the year for 2022 but
should also be considered a couple of
the best games of all time for me Elden
ring takes that mantle for the best game
I've ever played for its influence on my
life in more ways than one thanks for
watching guys I hope you enjoyed this
new format another guy named Jake
standing in front of a green screen
right I just need an inflatable ball to
sit on and I'm basically naked Jakey I'm
still deep in the works with the fallen
leaves which is turning out to be a much
more major project than I anticipated
and it might take a little bit more time
than the end of November to get the
first episode done it's a lot of work
but I'm Gonna Keep at it and take my
time with it to make sure it's good
enough for me to give to you guys I'm
just really passionate about it so I
want to make sure I've done everything I
can to make it as good as it can be
before I release it but like I said I'm
not gonna rush it I'm just gonna take my
time until it gets done I'll be live
streaming the game awards on December
8th hopefully we get some Elden ring DLC
announcement with that as well that
would be really cool to see live that's
all I gotta say have a good one bye guys